The problem is that what they want,
could they say
clearly to the French what they wish ?
I say,
for them,
immigration is not a problem,
it is 1 project.
And besides,
each time they put 1 text in place,
it's actually,
uh.
To ask the question of how
welcome immigration,
how to better welcome it,
how to implement the conditions,
infrastructure,
staff to welcome immigration.
Okay, and.
And. And.
And. So, uh.
Uhm, uh. Uh.
I don't think so at all
that this law is likely to regulate
the immigration problem.
I think
that it is not likely
to solve the problem of
obligations to leave French territory,
including Darmanin,
for the time being,
bears the responsibility,
and which only 7% are executed.
7% is ridiculous,
you have to tell yourself that,
and it got worse over the years